county leaders have just a few months
left to put new regulations in place for
homes listed on sites like airbnb that's
because of a state law requiring a
decision by july first so tonight the
public got a chance to voice what they
want to see madison kimbrough was at the
meeting and joins us now with what they
talked about madison clark county
commissioner ross miller hosted the
meeting as the majority of people were
in favor of the short-term rentals
however not so much for some of the
regulations involved
that as long as you do it right there's
no problems screening people
making sure you're not getting bachelor
parties and party house kind of stuff
short-term rental hosts gathered at
tuesday night's town hall to go over the
proposed regulations in allowing rentals
like airbnbs and verbo to exist in
unincorporated clark county those
rentals were illegal until the nevada
legislature passed a law requiring the
county to enact an ordinance regulating
short-term rentals by july first but
with these regulations come some
drawbacks according to some distance
requirements from house to house i'm
concerned that they might add an
owner-occupied stipulation to the county
we should not be punished because
the hotels perhaps were going to compete
against them
or because a few neighbors
are complaining because there are other
noisy neighbors other regulations
include an annual fee and a ban of more
than 16 people at the house at a time
and as for those who were opposed to
these short-term rentals altogether they
made sure their voice was hurt as well
just had a
short-term rental established directly
behind my back fence
and
i'm getting trash over my fence
loud
music at night
i think that they
should be regulated
the next county meeting to discuss
short-term rentals will be this thursday
that's going to be hosted by
commissioner jones we have the location
and time of that meeting up on our
website live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now